dann rufe ich auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 12 bis 12 d und hier
meine damen und herren beim neuen
tagesordnungspunkt geht es um die
filmförderung es gibt eine menge anträge
verschiedener fraktionen die
bundesregierung will die deutsche
filmbranche modernisieren in zeiten der
korona pandemie soll sie
anpassungsfähiger gestaltet werden
klimafreundlicher gerechter gegenüber
den geschlechtern und auch eine faire
verteilung der fördermittel ist in dem
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
vorgesehen
das gesetz soll allerdings nur für zwei
jahre gelten wegen der korona pandemie
könnte man die entwicklung und die
notwendigkeiten für die filmförderung
nicht mehr in der tat bereit in zukunft
abschätzen deswegen also jahren
verkürztes eine verkürzte laufzeit
vorgesehen elisabeth motschmann die
sprecherin für kultur und medien der cdu
csu
es gibt keine magie die so groß ist wie
im kino wenn das licht ausgeht
bruno ganz ich hoffe dass das licht in
vielen deutschen kinos nicht für immer
aus bleibt unsere kinos sind durch die
pandemie schwer getroffen
in der stadt und besonders auch auf dem
land es muss unsere kulturpolitische
aufgabe sein unser land vor einem kino
sterben zu bewahren
wie geht das erstens die kilos müssen so
schnell wie möglich wieder öffnen dürfen
zweitens wir brauchen gute filme und
drittens dafür braucht die
filmwirtschaft verlässliche finanzielle
unterstützung und das regeln wir im
filmförderungsgesetz heute an über 900
standorten sind die kinos geschlossen
bleibt die leinwand dunkel mehr als
25.000 beschäftigte sind direkt
betroffen
den schauspielern sind viele engagements
entgangen
die verleiher haben viel geld in das
marketing von filmen gesteckt zwei lockt
downs haben ihn wiederholt einen strich
durch die rechnung gemacht
die zahl der kinobesuche gingen in
europa 2020 um 70 prozent zurück der
stärkste einbruch in der geschichte
bund und länder und auch die
öffentlich-rechtlichen rundfunkanstalten
haben geholfen wo immer sie konnten
der etat der filmförderungsanstalt für
20 20 wurde um 30 millionen erhöht es
wurden ausfall fonds für den corona
bedingten abbruch von produktionen
geschaffen dass neustart kulturprogramm
von staatsministerin monika grütters
enthält eine reihe von förderlinien zum
beispiel für die kinos und die verleiher
doch damit nicht genug durch den
besonderen einsatz von monika grütters
wurden auch die solo selbstständigen
hilfen für schauspieler besser angepasst
das ist eine berufsgruppe wir wissen es
alle die fast immer durch den rost
befallen wäre auch die programme des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums werden von
den unternehmen der filmbranche stark
nachgefragt zum beispiel das
mittelstandsprogramm digital jetzt diese
maßnahmen müssen wir verlängern und hier
und da verstetigen denn die
nachwirkungen der pandemie werden noch
eine weile bestehen
ich freue mich dass unsere
bundeskanzlerin kürzlich ein gespräch
mit kulturschaffenden geführt hat und
auch hilfen in aussicht auf verlängerung
von hilfen in aussicht gestellt hat
zugegeben der deutsche film kämpft auch
unabhängig von der korona pandemie mit
problemen der marktanteil an deutschen
filmen könnte in unseren kinos
es werden zwar viele filme produziert
aber nicht alle haben oscar qualitäten
wann hat ein deutscher film eigentlich
zuletzt einen oscar gewonnen
deutsche filme werden auf den
internationalen a festival selten
gesichtet
dafür allerdings können wir die bundes
filmförderung nicht waren sportlich
machen
ich sehe folgende probleme zu viele
förderer auf landesebene fordern
drehorte in ihrem bundesland zu viele
fernsehredakteure bügeln ecken und
kanten in den drehbüchern kleid sie
glauben so würde der film kompatibler
für das fernsehen und im übrigen ist die
filmförderung vieler bundesländer noch
ausbaufähig ich ahne schon die
opposition wird klagen und uns erklären
was an der bundes filmförderung alles
schlecht ist auch jan böhmermann
spöttelt gute deutsche filme entstehen
nicht wegen sondern trotz des deutschen
filmförderung system
diese kritik ist überzogen und falsch
die filmbranche hat es verdient dass wir
sie nach besten kräften unterstützen und
das geschieht auch sie haben hygiene
konzepte entwickelt in den kinos und am
set sie hat sich mit rasanter
geschwindigkeit an die pandemie an
anforderungen angepasst trotz corona
wird zurzeit viel gedreht das liegt auch
an dem ausfall von den wir geschaffen
haben mit der hilfe von monika grütters
und es gibt einen hoffnungsschimmer die
sommer berlinale soll als open air
veranstaltung im juni hier in berlin
stattfinden am ende meiner rede habe ich
noch einen wunsch an die produzentinnen
und produzenten engagiert bitte mehr
regisseurinnen und drehbuchautorinnen
die diesjährige oscar-verleihung hat
bezeichnet er ist die zweite frau konnte
den oscar für die beste regie gewinnen
und das im jahr 20 21 also da ist noch
viel luft nach oben liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
damit ist klar frauen haben bewiesen
dass sie hervorragende leistungen auch
in der filmwirtschaft erbringen können
wir brauchen mehr davon
vielen dank und die verlängerung des
gesetzes machen wir natürlich
unterstützen wir natürlich ja das war
elisabeth motschmann sprecherin für
kultur und medien der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion bei der
anhörung stellte sich heraus dass
vertreter der film- und kinobranche eine
umfassende reform der filmförderung in
deutschland fordern
allerdings liegen die ansichten der
kinobetreiber produzenten verleiher und
fernsehsender mitunter sehr weit
auseinander markierungen jetzt für die
afg obmann im ausschuss für kultur und
medien
meine damen und herren filmförderung in
deutschland ist wirtschaftsförderung
einer branche die gar nicht imstande
beziehungsweise willens ist
wirtschaftlich zu arbeiten
lieber werden durch förderung erzielte
gewinne privatisiert und verluste
sozialisiert
das schrieb lars henrik gass leiter der
internationalen kurzfilmtage oberhausen
2015 in einem faz artikel und er
bestätigt damit genau meine ausführungen
vor zwei monaten hier an dieser stelle
das system erzielt die akteure also sich
möglichst unauffällig im brot zu halten
und nicht dazu filme zu entwickeln die
es wert sind sagt er weiter heraus komme
eine diktatur des mittelmaßes das ist
leider die wahrheit und das muss ein
ende haben
hinzu kommt immer öfter politisch
korrekter kitsch wie im falle des antifa
films und morgen die ganze welt der als
deutscher beitrag für den auslands-oscar
grandios gescheitert ist das ausland
will ganz offensichtlich nicht mit
deutscher kampf gegen rechts propaganda
beglückt werden die politisch korrekte
gesinnung macht eben noch keine guten
filme meine dann einfach das ganze
system der filmförderung bedarf also
einer grundlegenden reform statt aber
eine solche endlich vorzulegen wie die
halbherzige gesetzesnovelle der groko
allen ernstes mehr
geschlechtergerechtigkeit und diversität
herstellen
die grünen erklären diese in ihrem
antrag sogar zum zentralen problem der
filmförderung das hat bei ihnen ja schon
obsessiven charakter angenommen die
feministische lobbyorganisation drohte
vielen bilder soll nach dem willen der
grünen einen platz in der verwaltung
verwaltungsrats der
filmförderungsanstalt bekommt die grünen
führen ja immer so gerne die
kunstfreiheit im munde und geben sich
hipp und kultur unter einer grünen
bundesregierung wurde die kunst so sehr
gegängelt reglementiert und politisch
korrekt auf linie gebracht wie seit den
zeiten der ddr nicht mehr meine damen
und herren gott bewahre uns vor so einer
und wer glaubt wer glaubt ich übertreibe
herr grund lädt hören sie mal zu sollte
einen blick werfen auf die filmförderung
hamburg schleswig holstein wo es heute
schon checklisten für politische
linientreue sozusagen gibt auf deren
webseite heißt es ab sofort sind
antragsteller innen dazu verpflichtet
einen fragenkatalog zur diversität ihres
geplanten projekts zu beantworten sie
sollen so sollen sie zur bewussten
beschäftigung mit dem thema diversität
und zur kritischen überprüfung des
eigenen handelns angeregt werden sehen
wir im geplanten filmprojekt menschen
mit behinderung wie viele frauen sind in
leitenden funktionen am projekt
beteiligt gibt es im team people of
colour und wenn nein warum nicht wir
wissen heißt es dann noch dass diese
checkliste nur ein anfang sein kann
meine damen und herren wenn das nur ein
anfang ist man etwas ist dann das ende
vielleicht dass die künstler sich
entscheiden müssen für eine
künstlerische praxis die durchdrungen
ist von dem bewusstsein dass in der
kunst nur nützlich ist was dem
sozialistischen aufbau die paul rilla
originalton ddr 50er jahre
es klingt wie eine drohung aus der nahen
zukunft
eines ist sicher geniale filmemacher wie
woody allen in mahlberg mann rainer
werner fassbinder oder verliehen hätten
in einen derartigen ideologisch
totalitären regulierungssystem auf dass
wir hier zu steuern
keine chance gehabt aber das sind ja
auch alles lauter alte weise männer die
sie ohnehin loswerden wollen unser
antrag verteidigt die ästhetik des films
vor dem hypo moralismus und schlägt
substanziellere vor maßnahmen bei den
voerder gremien vor in der referenz
filmförderung im sinne von
wirtschaftlichkeit und fairer
mittelvergabe und auch wenn sie unserem
antrag ablehnen werden das publikum wird
den filmen die sie hier heranzüchten
wollen an der kinokasse die rote karte
zeigen spätestens beim export versuch
ins ausland wird sich das totale
scheitern dieser filmpolitik
förderpolitik erweisen nur leider wird
bis dahin viel steuergeld verstehen
worden seien und die talente die wir in
deutschland haben werden sich auch nicht
richtig entfalten können und ein letztes
wort zu frau rottmann was die kinos
angeht öffnen sie sie doch wie dass sie
regieren doch beenden sie diesen
schädlichen und sinnlosen lockt das war
doch eine heuchelei wachsen hier
vorgetragen haben vielen dank
der bundestag debattierte über die
filmförderung der nächste redner kommt
von der spd martin rabanus er ist obmann
im ausschuss für kultur und medien für
seine fraktion
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen möchte sie einladen 45 minuten
gedanklich zurück zu gehen in der zeit
weil der beitrag von herrn doktor jungen
hat ja nicht wesentlich überraschendes
gebracht dass die gegen diversität gegen
klimaschutz gegen gleichberechtigung in
der gesellschaft sind wussten wir auch
vorher sie haben das noch einmal
hinterlegt stattdessen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen möchte ich gerne bei der
kollegin motschmann knüpfen die noch mal
sehr klar aus geführt hat dass die
koalition sich sehr intensiv nicht nur
um die kinos die auch aber auch um die
branche insgesamt gekümmert hat nicht
nur in der korona pandemie da auch aber
auch schon vorher und das ist auch eine
gute nachricht daran dass führen wir
auch ford mit der novelle des
filmfördergesetzes natürlich ist es so
dass wir eine große novelle forderung
natürlich darauf haben wir auch eine
evaluierung gegründet die grundlage für
eben diese große novelle sein sollte
stattdessen steht diese kleine novelle
unter den vorzeichen der korona pandemie
dabei ist richtig wenn sie liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen auch der
opposition sagen es müssen große
schritte folgen
das ist vollkommen richtig ich mache mir
nicht alles zu zeigen was jan böhmermann
gesagt hat aber wir müssen natürlich
schauen dass eine filmförderung im
umfang von über 400 millionen euro mehr
in anführungsstrichen ps auf die straße
bringt und mehr erfolgreiche filme
hervorbringen das ist allerdings
tatsächlich dann die aufgabe
für die kommende wahlperiode wenn wir
auf einer neuen grundlage nach corona
tatsächlich das ffg neu aufstellen
können
dennoch ist diese novelle wichtig denn
wir sicher das herzstück des ffg ab das
ist die filmabgabe aber auch darüber
hinaus setzen wir natürlich politische
akzente
mit dieser kleinen ffg novelle so
erweitern wir geht aufgabenbereich der
ffh um die durchsetzung faire
arbeitsbedingungen das ist uns
insbesondere als sozialdemokraten aber
auch in der koalition insgesamt wichtig
wir betonen die diversität wir betonen
die inklusion auch und die
geschlechtergerechtigkeit in den efsf
gremien erneut das sind wichtige
fortschritte
ein anderer wichtiger fortschritt ist
tatsächlich die verankerung des
klimaschutzes in dem film produktionen
durch das ffg aus der anhörung heraus
haben wir noch die regelungen der
sperrfristen aufgenommen das war ein
besonderer wunsch der kino verbände zu
sagen wir wollen die möglichkeit
erhalten von den starren sperrfristen
abzuweichen auf der grundlage einer
branchenvereinbarung die sich die nach
regeln die sich die etwas in der ffh die
branche selber gibt durchgeführt werden
kann ich bin sehr gespannt ob das ein
wirkungsvolles instrument sein wird auch
das werden wir in zwei jahren etwas
genauer einschätzen können schließlich
wir machen das ffg auf pandemie tauglich
aber ich sage dazu ich hoffe dass wir
diese regelungen die wir aufnehmen nie
brauchen auch das hat kollegin
motschmann schon gesagt es gibt ja
hoffnung es gibt licht am ende des
tunnels die inzidenz zahlen sinken die
impfkampagne funktioniert und
tatsächlich
in berlin freuen wir uns im juni den
open-air teil der berlinale tatsächlich
auch erleben zu dürfen
abschließend liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen möchte ich allen danken die
mitgewirkt haben an dieser novelle dem
koalitionspartner aber auch der
opposition die konstruktiv sicht mit
eingebracht hat in vielen
gesprächspartnerinnen und
gesprächspartnern die wir haben und ich
freue mich darauf in der nächsten
wahlperiode wenn die wählerinnen und
wähler meinen arbeitsvertrag hier um
vier jahre verlängern
bei der großen novelle mitwirken zu
dürfen
ganz herzlichen dank das ist ein mandat
der kollege rhabanus und kein
arbeitsvertrag
nächster redner ist der kollege thomas
hacker fdp thomas hacker als
medienpolitischer sprecher der fdp
der kollege der bahn ist es einfach zu
lange seeger präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
ende märz haben wir uns in erster lesung
mit der verlängerung des
filmförderungsgesetzes beschäftigt eine
wirkliche wenn ihr auch überfällige
novellierung in der auch die veränderten
realitäten in der branche und die
gravierenden umbrüche im zuschauer
verhalten hätte reagiert werden können
konnten sie liebe koalition unter
verweis auf die kolonne pandemie nicht
vorlegen
zum glück greifen ja wenigstens viele
der zuletzt vorgelegten änderungsanträge
die vorschläge der branchenexperten auf
das ist richtig das ist aber auch
allenfalls pflicht keine kür der
deutsche film und unser
produktionsstandort haben wir verdient
als vielleicht amüsante bürger marcel
risse wie wäre es mit internationaler
anerkennung kann auch mal wieder einen
oscar eine goldene palme oder einen
goldenen bären
wir freien demokraten hätten uns mehr
mut und entschlossenheit für eine
zukunftsfähige filmförderung gewünscht
diese zu entwickeln ist die dringende
aufgabe unmittelbar zu beginn der
nächsten legislaturperiode wir freien
demokraten wollen daran mitarbeiten
das aktuelle system der filmförderung
ist zu bürokratisch zu detailverliebt zu
zerfasern alles im allen zu weit von der
realität der filmschaffenden entfernt
mit produktionstechnischen film
tourismus durch die bundesländer werden
wir keinen erfolg haben
aber genau diesen erfolg wollen wir an
den heimischen kinokassen eine
zielführende förderung muss daher mehr
sein als eine föderale location pflicht
als gegenleistung für zuschüsse die
förderung
die förderung muss sich an der qualität
des films messen nicht an der
bereitschaft der produzenten auch mal in
wanne eickel oder garmisch partenkirchen
zu drehen
ganz zu schweigen von der pflicht jeden
vater antrag mehrfach in der ganzen
republik zu stellen das gegenteil jedoch
richtig wir brauchen verlässliche und
einfache prozesse die langfristige
planungs und rechtssicherheit für die
große schaffen so stärken wir den
filmstandort deutschland müssen uns doch
alle das kino ist wichtig nicht nur als
motor der filmwirtschaft sondern auch
als gesellschaftlicher resonanzraum
kino bietet raum für das gemeinsame
erleben von geschichten nimmt uns mit
auf intellektuelle und emotionale reisen
bietet anlass zum diskutieren und
philosophieren
ein guter film spielt in unseren köpfen
weiter auch dann wenn der vorhang
gefallen ist
wie sehr sehen wir uns danach dieses
erleben auch wieder in unserem täglichen
leben zu halten
kreativ in unserem land ganz gleich ob
vor oder hinter der kamera am mischpult
in der maske oder den kostümen haben
unzählige maße unzählige male bewiesen
wie viel kreativität kunst und können in
ihnen steckt dieses potential konnten
wir bei zahlreichen produktionen
beobachten operation walküre monuments
men das leben der anderen oder toni
erdmann seien hier nur exemplarisch
genannt zudem haben wir renommierte film
standorte und mit dem studio babelsberg
seit über 100 jahren 1 5 standort mit
weltweitem renommee in direkter
nachbarschaft wenn wir also keinen
mangel an filmischen und
schauspielerischen ideen kreativität und
exzellenz in deutschland haben scheint
das amt system zu liegen lassen sie uns
das ändern
zügig danke
[Applaus]
jetzt verteidigt das war beruhigend
doris appel will herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen die novelle des
filmförderungsgesetzes sollte ein
größerer wurf werden wegen der umstände
jetzt benannt worden
contento was bescheidenes daraus werden
neu sind krisenbedingter anpassungen die
etwa flexiblere förderansätze ein paar
wenige akzente zu arbeitsbedingungen
diversität nachhaltigkeit wir bedauern
sehr dass die umfassende reform vertagt
wurde denn gerade jetzt braucht das
große linien und hoffnungsschimmer für
die zukunft statt mode pflaster und
zaghafte details viele filmschaffende
und kinos eigentlich alle sind seit 14
monaten stark gebeutelt könnten nicht
mal planen wir sehen dass uns stehen
entsprechend viele anträge dazu die
panini hat die branche tatsächlich stark
ins wanken gebracht und alte
handlungsbedarfe massen verschärft die
koalition erklärt sich dazu so dass das
gesetz ja nur der trailer zu einem
tollen film ist der dann in zwei jahren
starten soll setzt selbst in einem
solchen taylor sollten aber themen
aufscheinen die später in szene gesetzt
werden und das ist viel zu wenig
erkennbar
der reformbedarf das filmvater systems
ist bekannt sechs bis sieben jahre
kreist ein drehbuch durch die
filmförderanstalt von bund und ländern
diese zermürbenden strukturen müssen
verbessert werden
auch in sachen geschlechtergerechtigkeit
ist viel zu tun nur jeder fünfte film
wurde hierzulande in den vergangenen
gehen jährlich mit einer regisseurin
umgesetzt eine kleine anfrage von uns
zeigte dass frauen in der branche
verstärkt auf niedrigen gehaltsstufen
verharren trotz höherer qualifikation
dieses gleichstellungs defizit setzt
sich bei ungleich verteilten
fördermitteln gremien plätzen und an
vielen stellen fort und das kann einfach
nicht sein
allgemein ist die situation der
beschäftigten im film ein soziales
wagnis tarifverträge und arbeitsschutz
spielen in der filmbranche eine
untergeordnete rolle dass es nicht
akzeptabel schon gar nicht wenn
steuergelder fließen
die novelle bleibt auch dieser
problematik gegenüber sehr verhalten es
heißt die förderungs anstalt ffh solle
in der filmwirtschaft auf
selbstverpflichtungen für bessere
arbeitsbedingungen hingegen die wir
wissen kommt ihr mit
selbstverpflichtungen nicht weit deshalb
ist es notwendig dass fördermittel an
gute lohn und arbeitsbedingungen an
tarifverträge gekoppelt werden
es braucht braucht endlich gesetzliche
sozialstandards einen existenzsichernden
unternehmer/innen lohn für solo
selbständige auch und gerade hier
organisierte filmschaffende diskutieren
seit langem in welche richtung eine
filmpolitik fürs 21 jahrhundert weißen
kann diese debatte muss sofort noch
stärker gehört werden
der jetzige zustand ist nicht
erhaltenswert die deutsche kinobranche
ächzt unter den folgen der pandemie hat
einbußen von 70 prozent während das
privatvermögen von amazon chef bezos um
75 milliarden euro gewachsen ist letztes
jahr liebäugelte der pandemie gewinner
damit die welt größte kinokette
aufzukaufen
angesichts all der drohenden der weiter
drohenden monopolbildung und andere
entwicklungen in der film- und
kinobranche müssen wir uns grundlegende
fragen stellen welche zukunft hat das
kino als kulturort warum besteuern wir
die großen plattformen nicht endlich
eine sonderabgabe von panini profiteuren
im besonderen cool wäre angebracht
kommen wir zum schluss mit diesem geld
mit diesem geld könnten kommunale kinos
als demokratie stiftende kulturorte
etabliert und erhalten werden wir
bleiben dran und setzen auf eine
kombination die für die kino und
filmlandschaft die nötigen perspektiven
schafft vielen dank bundestag
debattierte über die filmförderung
nächste rednerin kommt von den bündnis
grünen tabea rößner
die sprecherin für verbraucher und
netzpolitik
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
gestern habe ich ein gespräch von jungen
leuten mit bekommen die sich riesig
darüber freuten dass die freilicht kinos
wieder öffne es dürstet die menschen
nach kultur um nach dem
gemeinschaftlichen erlebnis ins kino zu
gehen und dafür braucht es gute
spannende und anspruchsvolle filme
dieses ziel verfolgt die filmförderung
nun muss turnusgemäß das
filmförderungsgesetz novelliert werden
aber es ist eben nur eine mini novelle
und wenn staatsministerin grütters hofft
dass sie uns hier ein angebot macht das
wir nicht ablehnen können wir können
leider auch nicht zu stunden und bei
ihnen von der ard ist ja heute deutlich
geworden dass sie die filmförderung als
zensurinstrument verwenden wollen geld
bekommt nämlich nur was ihnen politisch
gefällt das ist ihre art von kämpfe
culture im gesetzentwurf bergen zentrale
punkte auf gemacht aber nicht zu ende
gedacht und unabhängig von der krise
manche aspekte dulden eben keinen
aufschub
zum beispiel die
geschlechtergerechtigkeit qualität im
präsidium und verwaltungsrat der
filmförderungsanstalt ist zwar dringend
notwendig es reicht aber nicht
denn das führt nicht automatisch dazu
dass frauen gleichermaßen gefördert
werden und es muss doch uns allen zu
denken geben dass frauen nach dem ersten
berufsjahren nach und nach aus der
branche verschwinden
mal abgesehen davon dass frauen ihre
budgets deutlich effizienter einsetzen
als ihre kollegen sollte unsere
gesellschaft doch nicht auf die
perspektive von 50 prozent der
bevölkerung verzichten müssen
wir wollen daher zielquoten bei der
vergabe der förderung im bereich regie
drehbuch und produktion nur so werden
wir echte geschlechtergerechtigkeit
erreichen und den deutschen film
bereichern
gute filme
brauchen gute ideen seit jahren hören
wir dass die stoffentwicklung gestärkt
werden muss
tun sie das auch und erfreulich ist auf
den ersten blick dass die koalition bei
den schwer fristen auf uns zugekommen
ist
doch es ist nur eine kann bestimmung mit
der von den regulären sperrfristen
abgewichen werden kann
die aktuelle situation zeigt aber die
sehr die branche unter der fehlenden
flexibilität bei der auswertung auch
leidet wir halten es für besser
stärksten zukünftig immer den
richtlinien der filmförderungsanstalt zu
regeln denn der geförderte deutsche film
darf nicht wegen seiner auswertungs
kaskade gegenüber internationalen
produktion in zitat treffen beraten
daher lassen sie uns die aktuelle krise
im klassischen sinn verstehen als
entscheidende wendung wir brauchen eine
generelle flexibilisierung der
sperrfrist nicht nur bei höherer gewalt
eine stärkung der ideenentwicklung aus
der dann die erfolgreichen filme auch
entstehen und diese müssen dann auch
klimafreundlich und nachhaltig
produziert werden und auch allen
zugänglich sein also barrierefreiheit
auch bitte zu ende denken diese vorträge
finden sie in unseren anträgen bedienen
sie sich da gerne die filmförderung bus
grundlegend reformiert werden
wir müssen die nächsten zwei jahre
nutzen um die filmförderung auch
wirklich modern und gerecht zu gestalten
kindern war jetzt schon häufiger von den
sperrfristen die rede war
bekommt ein filmprojekt gilt von der
filmförderungsanstalt gelten gewisse
voraussetzungen so muss zum beispiel der
film eine gewisse zeit exklusiv im kino
laufen und ist für andere medien
gesperrt
ja jetzt also die nächste neuen yvonne
magnas für die cdu/csu in diesem
zusammenhang wirklich auch mal sorgen
profitiert vom bkm programm
kultur so stark wie die filmwirtschaft
mit einer abflauenden infektions dynamik
und den zunehmenden verfolgen ist es
aber jetzt auch wieder zeit an die
zukunft zu denken und in die zukunft zu
schauen nun eigentlich hätten wir ja
heute oder in dieser woche eine große
novelle des filmförderungsgesetzes
beschlossen
nun ist es corona bedingt nur eine
kleine aber auch eine kluge novelle
geworden
der grund dafür ist schlichtweg dass
keine belastbaren daten für eine
neugestaltung des gesetzes gibt und
aufgrund der andauernden pandemie ist es
noch nicht absehbar wann sich die
auswirkungen der pandemie auf dem film
und kino markt verlässlich beurteilen
lassen
die notwendige datenlage wird wegen der
langen schließung der kinos frühestens
mitte 2022 vorliegen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der opposition
es wäre ein vollkommen falsches es wäre
ein fatales signal jetzt eine große
novelle zu machen und eine
neuausrichtung der filmförderung zu
beschließen wo die kinos immer noch zu
sind und der gesamte film aufgrund einer
weltweiten pandemie großen verwerfungen
unterliegt
wir brauchen mehr klarheit und aufgrund
dessen gibt es jetzt eine art
verlängerungs gesetz und ich möchte an
dieser stelle auch noch einmal daran
erinnern dass wir in der koalition
bereits vor corona ein breit angelegtes
fachgespräch hatten mit der branche mit
vielen inhaltlichen eckpunkte die wir
bereits erarbeitet haben
wir sind der frage nachgegangen wie der
deutsche film verbessert werden kann und
erfolgreicher gemacht werden kann
und an diesen zwischenergebnissen
sollten wir wieder anknüpfen wir müssen
aber auch schauen
das sich durch corona verändert hat und
das müssen wir einbeziehen um dann ein
großes ein großes neues sinnvolles
gesetz zu machen
dafür haben wir jetzt zwei jahre zeit
denn das gesetz was wir heute beraten
und heute zum abschluss bringen dauert
zwei jahre oder ist zwei jahre gültig so
können wir jetzt dann auch schneller und
sollten das auch relativ zügig tun
wieder in die inhaltliche planung einer
großen novelle einsteigen was sind jetzt
die konkreten inhalte mit blick auf die
verwerfungen durch die pandemie geben
wir dem verwaltungsrat die möglichkeit
die mittelverwendung jungen zu
flexibilisieren förderbedingungen und
hilfsprogramme anzupassen referenz
mittel können beispielsweise auch für
werbemaßnahmen bei der wiedereröffnung
genutzt werden
hinzu kommt eine flexibilisierung der
sperrfristen in fällen hören wir bald
sowie neue standards bei nachhaltigkeit
und geschlechtergerechtigkeit in den
aufsichtsgremien und dann liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen hatten wir eine
sehr gute anhörung im kulturausschuss in
der vor allem noch mal ein zentraler
punkt heraus gestellt wurde
ja die film- und kinobranche leitet und
corona aber bereits vor corona die
branche einer erheblichen dynamik durch
die zunehmende nutzung auto visueller
inhalte ausgesetzt
corona hat die entwicklung noch
beschleunigt und so verkürzten
beispielsweise große verlierer
auswertungs fenster auf wenige wochen
oder veröffentlichten einige filme
parallel im kino und in streaming
diensten und diese entwicklung wollen
wir uns mit dem vorliegenden gesetz
aufstellen und ich bin der kinobranche
sehr dankbar dass gerade aus ihren
reihen der vorschlag zu einer
branchenlösung bei den sperrfristen kam
dabei verhandeln die verbände
auf der grundlage einer sv richtlinie
eine abweichende vereinbarung der
kinoauswertung und meine damen und
herren ich glaube das ist das
wegweisende in die sorten novelle das
ist nämlich eine enorm große chance wir
ermutigen sagt vor allem für meine
kollegen kolleginnen aus der
unionsfraktion firmen wir ermutigen alle
beteiligten mit großer ernsthaftigkeit
diesem weg zu nutzen und eine gemeinsame
lösung zu finden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
deutschland braucht das kilo als kultur
und erlebnisort unser land europa und
die welt braucht gute deutsche filme mit
der heutigen verlängerung des ffg
sichern wir in pandemie zeiten die
filmförderung in unserem land und wir
schaffen gleichzeitig raum für eine
gründliche vorbereitung der großen
novelle mit einer neuausrichtung der
filmförderung herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
voraussichtlich letzte redner in dieser
debatte ist die kollegin ulla schmidt
spd
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
entscheiden heute über die
weiterentwicklung des filmfördergesetz
als wichtigen schritt um in 1 accent
legislaturperiode die große novelle zu
erarbeiten
aber auch mit der heutigen novelle
werden viele verbesserungen erreicht auf
die die kolleginnen und kollegen ja
schon eingegangen sind die stelle hier
nur die erweiterung der filmabgabe
anpassungen für mehr flexibilität aber
auch nicht zu vergessen das ansätze da
sind die gesellschaftlichen und sozialen
fortschritte für die filmbranche im
gesetz zu berücksichtigen und endlich
auch eine geschlechtergerechte und
paritätische besetzung in den gremien
der filmförderanstalt vorzuschreiben
wichtig ist auch dass der
aufgabenkatalog der filmförderanstalt um
die belange von menschen mit
behinderungen und diversität erweitert
wird und das auf faire
arbeitsbedingungen hingewiesen wird
das alles sind schritte zur verbesserung
für die auch für die arbeitsbedingungen
von frauen und männer aber sie reiche
nicht aus denn liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen auch nach der heutigen
verabschiedung welle gibt es einen
großen handlungsbedarf
die vielfältige gesellschaft in film und
medienbereich sichtbar zu machen und
bestehende ungleichheiten zu überwinden
dazu zählen die weiterhin bestehenden
geschlechtsspezifischen
einkommensunterschiede
dazu zählt die ungleiche und ungerechte
sichtbarkeit von frauen und männern vor
und hinter der kamera
und dazu zählt auch die weiteren
bestehenden soziale ungerechtigkeiten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen jenseits
aller einem kulturellen kreativen
engagement der beschäftigt sind auch in
der filmbranche ist die filmbranche auch
ein paradebeispiel dafür wie lückenhaft
die absicherung der menschen die in der
kulturbranche der filmbranche arbeiten
ist im fall von größeren und länger an
den einkommensausfällen wie wir sie
gerade in der korona pandemie sind sie
alle obwohl abhängig beschäftigt viel
schlechter abgesichert als abhängig
beschäftigte in feste
beschäftigungsverhältnisse
sie fallen durch alle raster obwohl sie
bereit sind mehr für ihre soziale
sicherung zu tun und obwohl sie bereit
sind in die bestehenden
sozialversicherungssysteme einzuzahlen
das wird ihnen durch den gesetzgeber
verwehrt und das geht auf dauer dich da
muss auch gehandelt werden unständig
beschäftigte also menschen mit einem
arbeitsvertrag bis zu sieben tagen
dürfen nur dann in die
arbeitslosenversicherung einzahlen
wenn sie das nicht berufsmäßig wachen in
diesem engagement
das trifft nicht nur die
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler
sondern das trifft auch die menschen in
der baske das trifft die menschen auch
hinter der kamera und viele andere mehr
und da muss mit schluss gemacht denn und
deshalb sage ich wenn der handel stoßen
dialog der ja hier im filmfördergesetz
angelegt ist für die nächsten zwei jahre
erfolgreich sein will brauchen wir zwei
bereiche in dem wir tätig sieht das
erste ist erkennen selbstverpflichtungen
in der filmbranche reiche nicht wir
brauchen klare bedingungen das branchen-
tarifvertragliche regelungen soziale
standards voraussetzungen sind für die
öffentliche förderung das gilt dann auch
die namibischen diversität der letzte
satz und wir brauchen dringend reformen
im bereich der sozialen absicherung weg
mit allen sonder regelungen abhängig
beschäftigte müssen zu gleichen
bedingungen versichert werden im 21
jahrhundert brauchen wir auch in der
film- und kulturbranche kein
tagelöhner mehr danken für ich lese die
auswahl zu tagesordnungspunkt 12 a
kommen jetzt zur abstimmung über den von
der bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur änderung des
filmförderungsgesetzes der ausschuss für
kultur und medien empfiehlt unter
buchstabe a zu einer beschlussempfehlung
auf drucksache 29 694 den gesetzentwurf
der bundesregierung auf der drucksache
27 5 15
in der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen
hierzu liegen zwei änderungsanträge der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen vor über
die wir zuerst abstimmen änderungsantrag
auf der drucksache jetzt 29 790 wer
stimmt dafür die grünen und die linke
stimmt dagegen die grünen wollen hier
dass der verwaltungsrat von 36 auf 38
personen angehoben wird ist aber gerade
abgelehnt worden vom deutschen bundestag
linke und die grünen bei enthaltung der
fdp
mit den stimmen der übrigen fraktionen
abgelehnt änderungsantrag auf der
drucksache 29 7 91 er stimmt dafür würde
die grünen die wägen wir sind dagegen
hier geht es um den park auf 53
sperrfristen werden ihre richtlinien der
film förderungsgesellschaft bei uns
etwas an stadt geregelt
jetzt bitte ich diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung auf
der drucksache 27 5 15
in der ausschuss fassung zustimmen
wollen um das handzeichen das ist die
koalition wer stehen dagegen die fdp die
grünen die linke während hält sich die
fdp
der secret sind wurf ist damit in
zweiter beratung angenommen und die
beratung und abstimmung
jetzt bitte ich dir in die dem
gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
dankeschön wir sind dagegen
dankeschön wer enthält sich dankeschön
der gesetzentwurf ist mit den gleichen
mehrheiten wie in der zweiten lesung
angenommen in der dritten lesung als
stimme wird in den schießanlage der
fraktion bündnis 90 grüne auf der
drucksache 29 7 92 wer stimmt für diesen
entschließungsantrag für die grünen
fordern unter anderem einen
solidarbeitrag des wenigen dienste
einzufordern
die übrigen fraktionen enthaltungen gibt
es keine der entschließungsantrag ist
abgelehnt
hier kommen zu tagesordnungspunkt 12 b
abstimmen die beschlussempfehlung des
ausschusses für kultur medien auf der
drucksache 29 694 der ausschuss
empfiehlt unter buchstabe b seiner
beschlussempfehlung die ablehnung des
antrags der fraktion der asc f der
drucksache 27 8 71 mit dem titel den
deutschen film erfolgreicher machen das
für ihn förderungssystem neu ausrichten
wer stimmt für diese bistums empfehlung
sind dagegen enthaltungen die
beschlussempfehlung ist gegen die
stimmen der afd
mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses
angenommen und der buchstabe c empfiehlt
der ausschuss die ablehnung des antrags
der fraktion der fdp auf der druck sei
als 27 822 mit dem titel zukunft für
großes kino deutsche filmförderung im
europäischen kontext reformieren
wer stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
fdp koalition die linke stimmte gegen
die fdp wäre enthält sich bündnis 90 die
grüne wiese will wissen mit den
genannten mehrheiten angenommen unter
buchstabe dies einer beschlussempfehlung
empfiehlt der ausschuss weiterhin die
ablehnung des antrags der fraktion die
linke auf drucksache 27 35 10 mit dem
titel filmförderungsgesetz reformieren
für vielfalt transparenz
chancengleichheit künstler künstlerische
qualität
und gute arbeit wer stimmt für diese
beschlussempfehlung koalition fdp hst
wir sind dagegen
bündnis 90 grünen die linke den verbiss
angenommen tagesordnungspunkt 12 c
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
kultur und medien auf der drucksache 29
6 95
der ausschuss empfiehlt oder buchstabe a
die ablehnung des antrags der fraktion
der fdp auf der drucksache 27 8 23 mit
dem titel die leinwand bleibt
unersetzbar für ein überleben der
deutschen film- und kinobranche
wer stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
die koalition und bündnis 90 die grünen
das sind dagegen
fd und fdp während hält sich die linke
die beschlussempfehlung gespielte
genannten mehrheiten angenommen und der
buchstabe b empfiehlt der ausschuss die
ablehnung des antrags der fraktion die
linke auf der drucksache 25 0 66 mit dem
titel existenz gefährdete kinos
filmverleiher und filmproduktion sicher
durch die krise bringen
wer stimmt für diese beziehungs
empfehlung die koalition fdp sind
dagegen die linke wer enthält sich
bündnis 90/grüne beschlussempfehlung mit
der genannten mehrheit angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 12 d dies empfehlen
jetzt für kultur medien zu dem antrag
der fraktion die linke mit dem titel
filmförderung geschlechtergerecht zu
geben
der ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf der drucksache
17 68 den antrag der fraktion der linke
auf sieben uns auf der drucksache 77 06
abzulehnen wäre steht verführen linken
fordern hier mindestens die hälfte der
filmförderung soll in projekte fließen
bei den frauen das sagen haben drehbuch
regie et cetera aber der bundestag hat
island